foreign
from Charleston I'm a little jealous of
your name sir Sterling how can we help
hey buddy I really appreciate that I'm
jealous of how smart you guys are right
well I'm about to expose that that is
unplaced jealousy here but we are going
to try to help you what's going on today
I appreciate it hey I have uh I've been
dealing I've been um listening and doing
the Dame Ramsey thing for the last five
years I'm I'm basically debt free now
because of the own I want to just thank
you very much for all that I really
truly do congratulations I'm a huge fan
and um but I did I was looking at um at
this solar thing I looked at the um the
last episode with Dave had a question on
there and I'm I'm just kind of curious
because the way I look at it is a little
bit different
um you know I like to say I'm debt free
but the way I look at it is my utility
bill is a debt and it's a lifetime debt
and if I go and put solar panels on my
home I'm going to eliminate that and
when my panels are paid off I'm not
going to have a utility bill or a solar
payment and that's when I actually
really own my own electricity I'm my now
my own electric electric company I'm not
depending on the local utility that has
ever changing increasing rate okay
sterling sterling you it's Sterling I'm
interrupting uh only because you have
proven to us all that you did a really
good job listening to their sales pitch
I feel like you've read the brochure
seven or eight times you nailed it yeah
you laid it out exactly the child goes
down Sterling's gonna have electricity
we're all coming to Charleston to to
have a grill out at Sterling's house
it's burgers and dogs no Sterling listen
all right so let me ask you some
questions I have gas appliances though
I'll still be able to cook those before
y'all but Sterling I want to ask you
some questions how much is it going to
cost you
because you're going to have to finance
it after from there the tax credits okay
it's gonna cost me roughly about ten
thousand dollars ten thousand dollars
total for your solar panels
after the tax credits after the 55 pack
because we get a 26 a 25 state tax
credit and we also get a 30 Federal okay
but how is that applied because again
you're nailing the talking points how
has that applied what's your upfront
cost it's more than ten thousand
no oh okay so it's 20 000. we'll call it
twenty thousand I know I've been down
this road before Sterling I get it
twenty thousand twenty Grand yep all
right and so how long is that gonna take
you to pay off
well it all depends on the loan so let's
say it's set up on a 10-year loan I'm
gonna put it on 10 years sure
and the loan payment is going to be less
than it's about twelve dollars less than
what my utility bill payment is uh-huh a
month
and it never goes up it's a fixed rate
really good I know so you're paying
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
borrow money to save money down the line
on your utility bill and I don't buy it
I don't believe that your utility bill
goes to zero
so you've bought that bill of goods too
that's not absolutely true I don't think
that's true I would challenge you to
research that a little bit more and the
sales guys it doesn't go to zero let's
say it doesn't go to zero let's just say
it's very minimal let's say it goes from
200 a month to thirty dollars a month
all right they do work they do do that I
get it brother so run the math on that
all right so we've saved how much money
on that example 170 right yeah 170 bucks
a month yeah per month times 12. I don't
have a calculator hold on let me get out
there we'll call it fit 1400 a year yeah
right so 1400 a year but you paid ten
thousand in loans plus interest here's
the deal if you want it so bad save up
the ten thousand and pay cash
okay that's my that's what I was gonna
ask you okay so don't borrow the money
bad thing okay don't borrow solar's not
bad I love the Sun
I need a little more sun look at me I'm
pasty I could use a little more vitamin
D Sterling but please come to Charleston
it's 85 today
once we were there yeah Sterling we're
never going to encourage anyone or
suggest to anyone to go into any kind of
debt even it's for the sun even for the
sun period a mortgage is the one type we
won't yell at you for but we have our
formula that we kind of run it through
but other than that we're not We're not
gonna sit here and say oh yeah you
should go take out a loan for 10 years
for solar panels because okay everything
I have read and again I'm not I'm not
deep into this I'm not a solar panel
really I know you're shocked I know
everyone's shocked even though I drive a
Tesla I'm not into solar panels this is
Mrs electric right now but most of what
I have read Sterling when it comes to
Renovations on homes and and getting the
value of your home up solar panels it's
a negative like it it does not increase
value for your home I know you're not
looking for the value of your home
you're looking for your utility bill
um so my thing would be because if you
want to say that the rates are going up
so much it's crazy what they've done in
the last even in the last 12 months I
mean I hear you 12 but Sterling you
gotta do it right but you got to do more
research than the company brochure that
they've and to make sure no I have I
don't know
yeah so listen do your solar panels I
think it's great if you want to do that
but just pay cash don't take out a loan
go into debt acquire risk for the fact
to have you so solar panels so that's
going to be true for anything uh
including the Sun